but we begin this half-hour with the
continuing threat from hurricane Harvey
the storm made landfall three weeks ago
today Harvey and the resulting floods
caused more than 70 deaths and damaged
or destroyed more than a quarter of a
million homes now as Houston and its
surrounding areas begin to recover
people there are taking steps to head
off a potential health threat Omar
Villafranca reports Harris County bug
experts are on a seek and destroy
mission the mosquito population is
expected to explode after hurricane
Harvey left behind countless pools of
stagnant water so this is why they
breathe on stafa de bon director of
Mosquito Control for Harris County says
these are the perfect breeding
conditions
how many mosquitoes could these two
tires breathe over 500 to 600 you know
700 you know because a mosquito will lay
a lot of eggs to combat the threat of
diseases like West Nile and Zika an
all-out assault has been launched
on the ground Harris County trucks have
sprayed more than 70,000 acres
and for the past several nights Air
Force Reserves c-130 planes have flown
over Southeast Texas spraying an
epa-approved mosquito killing chemical
the aerial bombardments have treated
more than 2 million acres of Harris and
other counties that's more than 10 times
the size of New York City but County
officials say they can only do so much
and need the help of residents
homeowners have hired personal mosquito
squads like Cory Barkham who says he's
been going nonstop it was priced before
the storm now phone calls are you know
when can you get to us can you do it
tomorrow can you do it today one of the
biggest problem areas are private
swimming pools like this one many were
flooded during the storm and have now
become breeding grounds for mosquitoes
officials are urging residents to treat
their own pools so they can stop the
growing mosquito problem for CBS this
morning Saturday Omar Villafranca
houston so many after-effects of that
storm thinking that it's not just that
moment yeah it just lingers and there
sits a long battle back all right